hey we're from group 7 we wanted to
introduce to truck oolitic how many of
you have used yelp have even ever eaten
at a food truck how many had a great
experience at the food truck how many
other an experience the future okay food
truck Google hits in the last five years
have exploded from 8300 228 million in
the past five years this shows how much
the food truck industry has been
disrupted in just the past few years we
want to do this in the mobile education
truck space in order to disrupt the
education mobile truck space for people
running these trucks they need to know
the best teaching practices then you
know best building and material tips and
what's needed out there and for people
using and learning from these
educational mobile trucks they need to
know what will you learn what's the
value of learning this way and what are
reliable reviews are the best trucks out
there like a Yelp for ED mobile truck
trucks truck oolitic accomplishes all of
this you guys have iphones or laptops
out you guys can type in ww arcola
descamps you want to check it out for
yourself and we are going to model how
to middle schoolers and put on my middle
school cap might potentially use a
website like chocolate lenox okay dude
did you two do oh man front rapala
science truck today ms Frizzles class
was so legit that rocket flying by my
face was amazing we should totally go
review it online oh what's that website
again chocolate eggs oh alright
we have tropical enix and wow I think
there's even a link to Facebook and
Twitter so I could tweet out how awesome
for tropical asst was and for our QA we
have the owner of fun topless science
truck who uses truck a lettuce to answer
questions for you other than one vision
engineering which presented here earlier
how many mobile trucks are there and
mobile ed trucks are there first of all
lots second of all not enough third of
all we want to empower them to share
their ideas so there'll be more and we
want to make them more effective faster
through collaboration they're competing
in some metra metropolis but the one in
Boston is not directly competing with
the one in Houston they could share
ideas when embossing sell stuff to the
one in Houston so that's an additional
fund raising source for them well if
they have the same student market
schools not going to have five trucks
day after day this happens today not
necessarily trucks any mobile education
we've actually met a lot of people who
do mobile education come to the school
even for teacher PD that could be a
mobile a truck but so so are you
considering any ed service as a truck
well any services that a school would
idea there are many diverse programs
right now that sort of take these really
dynamic interactive inquiry-based
experiences and bring them to the school
so it could be I'm thinking of something
through Harvard or through MIT where
they're taking these learning
experiences and moberly bringing them to
the school site and we heard some ideas
being pitched already today for other
more creative educational mobile trucks
to bring it so we're sort of
anticipating a market for ed mobile
trucks but as
this is very emergent very new trying to
share best practices so as we anticipate
a proliferation of these trucks but they
are able to share practices a lot of
students know to go to truckle it x2
review it absolutely so um as a truck
owner I would want them to on my truck
I'd have a sticker go review me on
charcoal it except more schools get me
we also have to have hope to have a
technology component to put into trucks
that would one health track where they
are so hopefully to facilitate posting
to our site and therefore for want to
empower these innovators to grow and
learn and become better faster through
this data big data analysis of what's
going on in the reviews and people